good morning everybody or good afternoon
or good evening depending on where you
are located in this big wide world
welcome and thank you for joining us for
this webinar with my uncle we're getting
a little bit of a late start we
apologize for that we had some technical
difficulties getting everybody connected
but we're here now and we will go a
little long so that we can make sure
that we accommodate everybody's
questions even in spite of our a little
bit of a late start here today we're
talking about AWS s3 and glacier
together it's the best of both worlds
AWS s3 of course is a storage cloud for
the internet glacier is an archival
service Amazon's s3 is a paid service
and is used by many businesses for quick
access to content across the internet
but many thought many times companies
are facing a situation where content is
not frequently accessed could place or
be the solution so today we're going to
present you an overview of the AWS s3
and glacier platforms and talk about
which of the two to use under different
circumstances now if you're not familiar
with our presenter my unk is has more
than eight years of experience in the IT
industry he's a seasoned professional
with experience and product development
and end-to-end implementation with a
focus on client engagement solution
design and delivery scope and resource
management he is of course AWS certified
Solutions Architect with experience in
cloud architecture and RFP RFI responses
for cloud before we get rolling though
just real quickly I want to make sure
everybody is familiar with their
dashboards and is hearing me ok so do me
a favor really quick and find the
questions module on your dashboard and
just type in a a hello to my aunt for me
and just let him know that you're
excited to get rolling and you're happy
that he's here and that way when I see
you saying hi in the questions module
I'll know for sure you're hearing me and
I'm not just speaking into the into the
darkness there we go
fantastic I see a couple of people
saying hello ah Nicole happy to have you
here Sajith
from India fantastic so it's evening for
you Thank You Ranjit
thank you for letting me know you're
hearing me that's good and pay attention
to that questions module because as we
go through this presentation which will
run about 35 or 40 minutes you can just
ask your questions there in the
questions module and we will loop back
around after the presentation and hit as
many of your questions as we can make
sure that we answer everything you need
to have answered if you want to share on
social you're free to do so go ahead and
live tweet of course if you hear
something super awesome and wise and
insightful that you want to share with
your audience go ahead and tweet or
Facebook or go to LinkedIn and post or
whatever makes you happy and if you want
you can use the hashtag SL webinars
alright that's certainly all you need to
hear from me I'm going to turn this over
to my friend mark and he's gonna take
care of laying down the wisdom for you
here today on AWS and glaciar my ugh
it's all yours my friend thank you
and a lot for the water for the warm
welcome Hey hi everyone thanks for
joining here we will be talking as we've
already told we'll be talking about
estimation today both of them are
actually different classes of storage
for the same thing but but you know the
scenarios when they are used that really
differs and it's very important for us
to understand when to use which one many
of the times people to commit mistakes
and you know because they do not
understand it fully so the intention
here in this webinar would be that we
will try to we will try to cover in what
we s3 works for we'll try to understand
what are the advantages of using that
what are the what are the typical usage
scenarios we'll also try to understand
how the pricing works for s3 and then
we'll go to play share we'll try to
understand the same in that case and
then we'll do a small comparison and
we'll try to we'll try to conclude
clearly that when we should be using
which one all right so
Amazon's s3 simple storage service this
is one of the I would say one of the
oldest AWS services right so it got
started a long time back and do I give
2006 itself and this has been this is
actually an object storage where where
you can go ahead and store any type of
your files and businesses around the
world they're using s3 for for a variety
of purposes right now it is very
important to understand though to start
with that what is that what is the
difference between an object level
storage or and a block you will store it
there are other AWS storage services
like EBS EFS etcetera which are block
level storage where the operations are
possible at block level whereas whereas
s3 is an object given storage meaning
the operations which can which are
possible on this particular storage type
are going to be there at object level
meaning at the whole file level which
means if you if you modify a particular
file or an object and you try to put it
again you need to basically replace that
full file right so did not go ahead and
use this as the disk of your ec2 that's
not what is what it is meant for right
it is it is it is architected itself to
be natively online so that you can
access it over HTTP or HTTPS protocol
you can store any amount of data on s3
from anytime you know anytime anywhere
you can access it and it's highly
scalable reliable fast and durable fully
managed service from on a tableau is
where you do not have to worry about
about deciding on the size that you know
you don't have to plan beforehand right
it's it's not like some of the other
storage services like when you normally
create an EBS volume do decide that
whether it should be 500 GB or it should
be a TB or more right you do not have to
plan here you you as soon as soon as you
get any amount of data you can put it on
s3 and you do not have to worry about
its durability all at all s3 gives you
gives you a durability of I'm really
sorry I think
okay so Esther gives you durability of
11 nines
which is ninety nine point nine times
nine percentage which means the chances
of losing your object once you put it on
is three that's really really impossible
right and this type of durability at at
really cheap cost right that is what is
making history popular among businesses
and they are have started using s3 as
one of their extension you know to save
all types of data with availability of
nineteen ninety nine point nine point
ninety nine point nine in percent well
or a given year now it's important to
understand that what type of or what
size of objects can you say one is three
you can save objects of up to five
terabytes meaning a one file can be of
maximum size of up to five terabytes
right in addition to that there is no
bucket size limit so you actually you'll
actually put all your objects in you
know in informal pocket so bucket is the
first logical entity which you create in
s3 and there you know after that you can
go ahead and put your objects you can
also categorize your objects in the form
of folders inside that there is no
limitation on the number of objects
which you can have so you can like it's
basically literally kind of unlimited
storage so you do not learn and AWS
internally takes care that you know it
continuously monitors the service and
you know continues to add more and more
amount of storage so that you never run
you never run out of storage right
you have HTTP and HTTPS endpoints in
place it is recommended that you use
HTTPS so that all the data which is
coming and going to s3 is always
encrypted it is highly scalable as we
talked about it already
whenever you put any data on as it gets
replicated automatically across minimum
of three availability zones which means
you can be sure that even if a complete
availability zone goes down you are not
going to lose your data it is going to
be available for you you have optional
suicide encryption available if you want
you can enable that and in that scenario
you will have all the data encrypted on
s3 or you will have all the data
available on a strain and
at forward it gives you option to use a
key coming from PMS key management
service or you can use your own your own
keys as well a customer provided key as
well you can be used it has facilities
of logging you if you enable logging all
the access logs get created that who
used the pocket and it won't write and
you can very well use it later on for
all the auditing purposes and of course
for all the different type of operations
be putting an object deleting an object
getting an outfit from history you have
standard rest and so interfaces
available some of the use case scenarios
in what way are people using history it
is primarily I would say a lot of
portion gets used for storage and backup
and application file hosting as you know
it but along with that in today's market
a lot of businesses have started using
using s3 for hosting all their media
files beat audio files or video files
because it works great right for example
you have a website where there you have
got some really high definition video
files which you are displaying there you
do not have to you do not have to plant
or for really heavy service to host that
instead of that take your files put it
on s3 maybe put cloud front as well in
between and with that you can stream it
doesn't matter how much your how much
your audience you know audience based
gross you do not have to go ahead and do
you know anything further your s3 scales
of will and it would be able to support
the bandwidth required to stream that
you know only all your videos it's
really good really good for that
software delivery people people are
delivering all their you know software
set of files on history and AWS uses s3
internally to store all your a.m. eyes
and their force you know previous
snapshots as well a lot of uses you can
actually run a computer static website
just out of this thing right without
people without hosting any server at all
that is perfectly possible and nowadays
with the latest with the latest on
production of a SS lambda you can very
well do a dynamic website as well or
this
let me give an example some of you might
have visited the website udemy.com it is
a website where you can go and learn you
know you can watch different video
tutorials and this Billy learn stuff
udemy is totally there on AWS and uses s
3 and lambda alone for the whole thing
to know that is not just a static
website it has part of it has got a lot
of other functionality is like you know
login account creation and all of that
and they are able to do that just with
the help of s 3 and lambda without
running any other service really great
stuff going on you need to understand
properly that how the pricing works in
case of s 3 there are three factors
which decide that what would be your
port will be your monthly drives first
of all no minimums with no minimum fee
so you start and you put your data the
amount of data which you put based on
that the cost its decided
right so the first factor is the storage
how much how much space or how much
storage or you can do on a spring second
is how many API requests are you doing
right so there are there are there are
there are a number of three API requests
which you get free every month over and
above that if you do more there is a
pricing there is a license lot for that
you can refer that in the documentation
that is how it gets price in addition to
these two things how much is the data
transfer out from mystic so you can
probably get probably post one of your
videos there like the example which we
have taken earlier and people continue
to wash their so data transfer out is
happening premiere s3 you get charged
for that right and there will be a small
variation in the price between you know
between different regions please look
for the region which is closest to your
audience
Plus which has to do with some concepts
should know quickly about s3 further s3
stores data as objects within pockets
which we talked about already an object
is composed of a file and optionally any
metadata that describes that file right
so that is what an object is is
essentially a file plus in addition to
that some metadata about it there is a
limitation that you can have only 100
pockets in an account and of course you
can control
accessed either to a bucket or dual
objects inside that with the help of
various policies bling bit deeper in the
s3 now if you create a bucket let's say
further let's say the bucket name is doc
and you go ahead and create a folder
within that on.200 6 - 0 3 - 0 1 and
then you put an HTML file within that
and this is how the URL gets form for
your object remember some time back you
are talking that you can actually you
can actually post a complete website out
of history right so that is possible
because any object which you put on s3
can be accessed over a you are right so
this is how it becomes and which also
gives you an idea why the bucket name
should be unique yes alright so people
might be worried about security at times
you need not be because AWS has planned
around the security of s3 and in a
release here you have different options
to secure your s3 popping you can use
acyl access control lists bucket
policies and identity and access
management now there are different uses
of all you can go ahead and use bucket
policies when you have to cross it down
to access you can go ahead and use AC
else when you want to give access within
the account for different users and I am
policies are used when you want to do
all the you know all the policy all you
want to keep all the policies and
permissions at a centralized place not
only for s3 but for other eight of duyst
services as well you can upload a
download data to Amazon s3 yi7 written
points it is a recommended as well
please use the HTTPS and of course
encryption is possible using a 2 plus
SDK AWS s3 also gives you versioning
facility right now many other times it
happens that you might be you know you
might end up deleting a file by mistake
right or purposefully you want to to
version management people go ahead and
use tools like yesterday and it's
that that might not be exactly equal to
SPL but if you if you enable versioning
it it saves you from a lot of stuff
right so what you do is you enable
versioning and then Amazon is three
maintains maintains different quotients
of your objects so let's say you have a
file today called photo dot yes and then
you upload a modified version of this
file tomorrow for the versions of this
file would be maintained with different
internal IDs right even if you go ahead
and delete a particular file
it is only salted it and it is not it is
not actually deleted right it is also
important to understand that with
versioning your cost increases but at
the same time you get the benefit that
you do not lose any file its identity
there can be three strips often Amazon
s3 bucket on version which is default
right when you create a new bucket
versioning is not enabled after that if
you want you can put and enable the
versioning once you enable the
versioning you can not stop it you can
suspend it that you cannot basically
disable it right okay so let's talk
about some of the webstore its stop this
is a problem for Mon of the organization
where they want to deliver large files
from a web server and that is actually
becoming a problem in terms of network
latency user-generated content needs to
be distributed across all your web
servers solution stole all your static
asset files in Amazon s3 and deliver the
files from there
now then asset files can be as small as
your CSS or JavaScript files and it
can't be also the huge files like your
mp3 audio and your video files all of
those points right and on things that
are stored in Amazon s3 can be accessed
directly by users if set to being public
so you have this option that you can go
ahead and change the visibility often of
an Amazon s3 object to public once you
do that just on the URL as we saw some
time back anybody can access your object
with that public URL now but you have to
be really cautious whether you want to
do
for your files or normal is if suppose
you are actually distributing your
content which you do not want just
anybody to do access right then in that
case you would you should not be making
it public rather there are other
mechanisms like pre-signed URLs or on
via always some particular website where
you know with which you fetch the data
or you fetch the object from s3 and then
throw it to you now it depends how do
you want to use it but both the things
are possible in case of history let's
talk about about the tearing or native
Lewis s not s3 alone actually I'll talk
about glacier also here now sometimes
people though on the on the management
console also you see as a completely
different so is there but glacier is
actually one more class of a storage
within s3
right there different classes of storage
in s3 earlier it used to be only s3
standard and Amazon play ship as time
passed new classes came up so one more
now is s3 infrequent access so now we
have got s3 standard we have got s3
infrequent access and we have got
glacier of course there is one more
reduce redundancy right I'll try to talk
about it after a while but between
between these it is very important to
understand that when you should lose
which one now we talked already about
s/3 s/3 is being used for all the files
which you want to which is which is
typically suitable for home usage wor
write once read multiple times right so
all your all your static files which are
part of a website actually actually suit
well or the s3 standard you put your
files there use it frequently a really
low cost of storage plus data transfer
out s3 standard is the right place to do
that now think of the second use game
people come and talk that I want to save
my data on s3 I want to take the
advantage of flow and hence want to save
it on s3 but I do not use it very
frequently maybe it was it is my birth
of type of potato right I take that of
come off from my own frame service and
then I want to save it on cloud
I would I would want to be I would want
it to be reliable and durable really but
but it's not that I use it very
frequently give me lower-cost right if
that type of scenario you come across
you need to use that class which is SP
infrequent access so okay this this
particular class is designed to keep the
data that are same with the same
durability of eleven nines but the only
condition is that it is supposed that
you will be not accessing it frequently
and the pricing also changes is small at
all there is an additional retrieval
free with every request in case of
infrequent taxes whereas along with that
the per GB storage charge in case of
infrequent access is actually lesser
than history standard right so that was
the case where where you should use
infrequent access the third class is
also a glacier and glacier should be
used when you want to actually archive
it as the name barely says archive the
data you should not expect to get you to
you to get your data or to access your
data off frequently any any data which
you put on place sure pause and you know
get stored as waltz and you will be able
to whenever you want to access the data
from glacier you have to basically
submit a job and as the result when that
particular job that is completed you
will be getting the access to the data
we'll talk about it in a while I want to
tell you quickly about the lifecycle
policies which are available in s3 and
it is a really wonderful wonderful stuff
actually in a state now what happens is
let's take a let's take an example where
you are probably storing log files from
your applications over on history so it
happens that every day every day once in
a day all your log files really heavy
log files come from the home from your
applications over and land who you're
asleep and you might want to keep it for
some time to the standard storage
because
if something goes wrong somebody reports
something you would want to go through
the walls and try to understand what
caused this problem right so you pray
you go ahead and create a lifecycle
policy on your history pocket where you
say any file which comes here in this
particular bucket keep it in the
standard keep it in the s3 standard plus
for 32 years after that move it to
glacier right and then probably let it
be there for one year 365 days and after
that delete it now
this lifecycle policy does two good
things for you first thing it takes out
the headache that you have to go and
manually move it from one class to the
other second thing it where it
essentially does this automatic movement
and saves cost as well for you
right because laysurs cost of storage is
even lesser than that obviously so now
this thing is of course configurable you
may choose for how much time do you want
to keep where and just set the life
cycle falls accordingly and things keep
moving automatically they're pretty good
stuff okay with that we'll come to play
share I can't tell you about this
glacier is your whole story right as the
name says play sure it's brainy coal
which means it I would not be moving
fast right so it should be used for all
your archiving purposes guys earlier
people used to do this tape stuff and
then on-prem but glacier is actually
challenging that and lots of business
you know you might have heard about
SoundCloud all of you would have used
download is like really thought they are
really high on s3 and play sure they
keep all you know they use glacier in
order to save all their musics which
they have all that music which they
thought plus they keep although all that
all the data on s3 for all the active
usage right and you never find bandwidth
issues there right that particular
website won't straight route is a good
example
now storage cost for glacier is as low
as point zero zero seven GP per month
right
before one it allows you to retrieve
data within fifty to five hours that's
what I was talking about once you once
you put a data once you put some data to
play sure
you cannot just get it immediately yeah
whenever you want to retrieve the data
you need to submit a job basically and
then you need to continuously poll for
that job completion or you can probably
use SNS to plug with the job and when
the job is completed you get notified by
an email or by or through other
notification means and then you will be
able to download your data right so
that's that's how it is for things you
don't need you know you don't need any
any any other separate infrastructure or
hardware in order to do all this so more
additional investments and you get an
infinitely scale right and at the same
time you pay only for what you use so
you do not have to plan that
how many terabytes or petabytes of data
you want to entice you just want to go
ahead and do that you do not have to
plan really good stuff and this with
your life cycle policies you can even
automate this the whole time as we have
pockets in case of Amazon history we
have what world's in case of plate ship
so once all so these are the logical
entities within which you go ahead and
put your archives are nothing but basic
unit of data in Amazon's relation will
be documents we use in soils any octal
anything of that sort organizations like
like pharmaceutical companies other
healthier companies they they have this
requirement of keeping the data for
really really long duration so some of
the some of the countries they need to
keep the data for the last ten years
twelve years like that now keeping it on
for him actually becomes really really
positive so it makes sense to use a
service like glacier on Amazon right
pink which actually gives you unlimited
amount of storage and this is my cure
ability at such a low cost right so in
today's today's world
lude losing data is something which
nobody wants and for that purpose this
is the answer all right now
to interact with glacier data there are
two ways Delta can be archived by Amazon
s3 - glacier and for that purpose you
should use Amazon s3 api's to you know
to retrieve the announcement you can
also use directly glacier AP ice and you
can put the data to glacier and then
retrieve it
retrieve files in the stored in Amazon
glacier by initiating a job request this
is what I was talking about there are
different ways in which you can separate
the job you can restore an archive by
date range and perform arrange retrieval
and then once you submit this job as
don't already it takes like sometimes
three to five hours it would take for
that job to be complete and data to be
available you need to continuously poll
for the job completion once it is the
state you'll be able to download some of
the key concepts related to glacier so
when you within the glacier you will
have account which is of course you know
who is who is actually owning that
particular world and who is going to pay
for it what does they equivalent of her
bucket as you have pockets in history of
what one's here which is a container for
an oil for all your archives you can
have up to 1,000 balls per account
archives are files or records which you
are going to put one file can be of
maximum 40 TV off sighs if that's like
really built in s3 you had five
terabytes here you've got 40 terabytes
and this whenever you put files and
index of that is of course maintained
and it gets refreshed every 24 hours now
there is something really important
while you while you plan to store your
value pan to store your data in pleasure
that you should talk to the mistake of
storing smaller finds there right so
what I'm essentially trying to say here
is that even if you have a lot of lot of
small fights one it makes sense that you
actually flub them you know probably put
all them together and except file and
then try to put it in relation because
you have you have and you have an
overhead there right but every hour time
you have 32 KB of Associated overhead
right and that would prove so let's take
an example which I have put here on the
slide
if you are trying to put something
something of 3.2 can be that means you
are spending 1% of the cost on overhead
right but if you put something even
smaller right like 1 KB then 97,000 is
going in over now why is it important
many of the times you we might have lot
of lot of small small images as part of
the business so let's say you have got
you know millions of images so the right
method is not try and save all those
images of 100 200 or 500 cable
separately instead of that trying to
clump them you know zip them into into
Pico finds of MPs or GBS and then go
ahead and put it into ablation that will
save money because you know the pricing
difference and it's very important to
understand that in what way which
particular service works I'll try to I
will try to compare this here and then
we will try to discuss you know and
we'll understand if you have some
questions is the this is a concluding
slide actually from my side where there
we are comparing the different classes
all right so I talked to you that there
are that there are four classes now
Amazon is three standard which came
across and it was there for a really
long time and then people came up with
this demand that we actually have data
we want the same amount of pure ability
but we do not want to access it very
frequently that gave birth to the
infrequent axis where your paaji big
cost is going to be lesser but your
retrieval costs are going to be more
then Amazon s3 standard in terms of
durability same durability you have in
both then goes with the glacier purpose
data which you put here should be rarely
accessed and there is a retrieval time
of several hours right so when you are
ready for that then only put it in
glacier so that it is it is a really
important to understand the difference
the difference which is there between SP
inflation SP on post clearly is there
for active storage
whereas glacier if therefore our timing
and dies do not mix that please you have
the fourth and recently introduced
to class which is produced a tendency
now I talked to you that in what manner
Amazon s3 actually actually a replicates
right or maintains different one
different copies of your data across
different availability so so that is
where that is how this minimum minimum
it would be replicated in three
availability zones
that's how as this design right but
people also have this type of demand
that I want to store some data on floor
I want to get benefited from the cheap
storage on cloud but that data is is
reproducible right incase if it's lost
I have mechanism to reproduce it right
so forth all that type of data we've got
fourth class introduced which is reduced
redundancy where you get even cheaper
amount of storage then s3 standard and
we need frequent access but here the
number of replicas would be lesser than
your s3 standard and infrequent access
that's why the durability is 99.99% but
you can be sure that out you could not
be lost but of course theoretically it
is lesser than sv standard and
infrequent access so you have four
classes in front of you and the
comparison in terms of fastest were fast
and durability as well now I think with
all the description which we had it
should be possible for you to take to
take the decision that when to use which
one but that I'll take a pause and I
will be open for any questions which
should have thank you fantastic thank
you so much my on super super thorough
and I'm sure that you know I've got a
few questions queued up here but before
we get to them really quickly I am going
to be a little bit selfish here and I'm
going to take over your screen for a
very brief about 60 second intermission
I'm going to ask everybody to bear with
me here there we go so what you're
seeing there is a real quick poll this
is a public facing webinar and what that
means is that you don't need to be
familiar with or a member of or training
with simply learn right now to
participate today we're happy to have
you here we enjoy doing this it's a
great way for us to give back to the
community
and share the insights and wisdom of our
SMEs to help people advance their
careers we do a dozen or so of these
every month maybe more across a variety
of disciplines some of them obviously
being AWS and cloud related we also do
data science project management six
seven Six Sigma pardon me digital
marketing and so forth but our core
service goes beyond just these webinars
the webinars are definitely valuable but
our core service is that we are a
business and technology training
provider we provide over 400 web-based
training courses in a wide spectrum of
skill sets including AWS including cloud
prince2 PMI om CP training courses these
courses are accredited by these
third-party certifying bodies and they
are designed specifically to prepare you
for the associated certification exams
based on the very latest of course body
of knowledge all of these courses are
designed and presented by our faculty of
experienced professional trainers and
you get structured courses you get video
lessons you get resources and hands-on
practical experience to successfully
prepare yourself to pass the related
certification test if you need it you'll
get lab exercises you'll get simulation
exams you'll get access to extra
platforms and software to run
experiments and get hands-on practice
with these skill sets you can expand
your skill set into new areas or you can
enhance the skillsets that you've
already got with additional trainings
and certification you'll also of course
get access to active moderated forums
and you can interact directly with the
faculty and other students there are a
variety of ways to join and participate
that give you different kinds of
learning experiences either where your
self guarded guided or where you are
participating in a live virtual
classroom where you get to interact with
a faculty member so if you want to learn
more just take the appropriate box we
will have somebody get in touch with you
and talk with you about the sort of
training that's available and help you
find the right solution for you to meet
your personal career goals thank you for
indulging me it's my my personal
contractual obligation to make
you have that information so I'm going
to go ahead and close out this poll now
and we can get back to the real reason
we're all here which is of course to
learn more about AWS and glaciar we're
back make just so you know just seeing
your screen again alright so again thank
you for that I'm gonna tackle the very
first question myself because it's a
very common one and the question is is
the recording of the webinar or the
slide deck available for us to see later
and the answer is yes usually most
webinars are recorded I can see here in
my dashboard that this webinar is being
recorded for us right now and they are
produced reviewed and edited and
produced and put on to various places
you may find it on the simply learned
side of course but you might also want
to run over to YouTube and subscribe to
our channel there and very often into
the recordings of these webinars vents
are also posted at YouTube for you to
review so please feel free to do that
alright
so Mike I've got a few questions here
and we are at 9:18 so we've got enough
time to tackle a few of them 9018 my
time of course 18 minutes after the hour
in any case so regarding s3 I've heard
in the past of something called a US
standard region is that still applicable
does that limit my ability to be able to
use Amazon s3 outside of the US let's
say or Europe are there any limitations
is the US standard region still a thing
okay all right guys
when this restarted yes it started with
that name for the u.s. standard but your
standard is nothing but but you're not
Virginia region so you would you would
be aware that there are different
regions in 802 s you have California or
not California you have Oregon you have
not Virginia or Tokyo Singapore all of
this US standard is nothing but North
Virginia and there is no difference when
it comes to when it comes to s3 bucket
if you create in North Virginia or you
create an Oregon or in any other region
so there there is no difference
essentially
just that there was a difference naming
different naming convention earlier but
now everything is referred as you know
there as there as the respective region
name perfect well that's good to know so
there is no limitation it's just kind of
an unfortunate naming nomenclature here
we have a question does that and you may
have answered this already by the way
sometimes these questions come up before
you get to a certain point but does the
AWS management console support Amazon
glacier I mean when it comes when it
comes to posting when it comes to
posting the files through the management
console you will be able to put it using
the lifecycle policies which which we
talked about so you have got life cycle
policies and s3 using that you will be
able to you will be able to move files
from s3 to Glacier other than that you
should you will have to try and use the
different glacial API is and put and you
know post your file installation very
good thank you I hope that answers your
question and then we have if I work in
the financial sector has AWS been
assessed based on financial services
regulations that are related to the SE
the Security and Exchange Commission the
SEC okay yeah these type of questions we
get many times people related to banking
and financial sectors sometime also you
know these life sciences or
pharmaceutical organizations
they'll have their they'll have their
worries before going to clout and of
course in the similar manner to a place
as well
so they're what I what I would like to
explain is AWS actually meets most of
the stringent demands all the
certifications or accreditations which
are there in the world there is a
dedicated page on a tip list website you
can you can just google AWS
accreditations and certifications you'll
get a will get a dedicated page on their
website where you'll be able to see all
the possible you know all the possible
certifications which they have they have
all these things like PCI DSS and HIPAA
compliance and all of that one more
thing to note there AWS has
dedicated region for us comet called AWS
cough cloud and there are workloads of
NASA running on AWS you know many of the
US government organizing the US
government departments run that load on
AWS so that kind of you know gives the
gives the gives the guarantee to you
kind of that you know it is it is good
to run anything which you want and of
course if you want to go into the
details you can go on that particular
particular webpage and look at all the
certifications which we do business part
perfect thank you for that and
particularly yeah mentioning HIPAA to so
not only the financial services industry
but the the health services industry a
HIPAA is in particular a huge issue
there so that's good to know
let's see here let's find another
question with regard to certification in
the job market what advantage does AWS
training and certification offer me in
the job market does a truly increase
higher ability do employers really look
for certified experts over non-certified
or as practical experience more valuable
than the certification thanks for
bringing it up
a certification alone just for the sake
of certification is not gonna give you a
right but at the same time if you have
two people who have got good practical
knowledge and one out of them is
certified and another one is not you can
be sure that the employer is going to
pick the one who is certified right then
adds that extra badge on it on your on
your sleeves I would say now that that
is that is that is just a general object
or just a general observation in
addition to that when it comes to eight
of the certification the good thing in
case of a tip lewis is that the AWS
certifications have i've still got that
reputation in the market right the
amount the amount of you know the amount
of professionals which are needed in the
market compared to that we have got very
less professionals currently that's
that's point number one
second thing is AWS certifications have
got a reputation and the reason being I
would say the victim
the way they maintain their
certification they keep bringing the
change which actually which actually
makes it makes it difficult at times to
pass it right and hence you should have
real knowledge to clear the
certification right you know all of us
would know about some other
certifications which are which are very
easy you can just go anytime and just
you know reach somewhere and pass it
compared to that AWS is going to be
difficult understand till you have got
practical knowledge and you have done
things well you would not be able to get
it up this certified and once you are of
course it increases your chances and
value in the job market people are going
to value you lost more and it is trust
me if you go if you go and Google about
it and try to find out which are the top
which are the top paid certifications in
the world then you are going to find a
double use in the top three that I'm
sure so if someone does have this
certification they should certainly be
including it obviously on their resume
on their LinkedIn and and so forth so
definitely letting potential clients or
employers know that that's the case and
making sure that it's visible on their
various profiles let's see here
well this is sort of a related question
if I'm learning AWS and pursuing a
certification is it also helpful to be
knowledgeable or certified in other
platforms like Azure or Google is there
an advantage for professionals that are
familiar with multiple platforms and I'm
thinking maybe particularly if a company
is is migrating from one platform to
another is there an opportunity there
for folks who are multiply certified the
answer to this is yes and no I hate food
the way it works guys as you you know
depending I would actually say that you
should decide this based on the use of
experience you have right now people
with people with you know mostly up to
810 years of experience I think for them
it would make lot of make a lot of sense
to be certified
and have depth of knowledge on on one
platform but as you grow further it
makes sense that you know that you
actually grow your knowledge base and
you are and you should be knowledgeable
on two three to three platforms so now
if you if you take the current scenario
of those AWS is there is there is the
leading cloud provider followed by su
and after that probably the Google clock
right but that's how it is now
now as you grow further in your career
just to sticking to one but not give you
a lot it would make sense that you
actually are aware of aware of top two
three things in the market so that when
it when it comes to when it comes to
designing when it comes to designing the
strategy for your organization or for
any new product you can choose the best
right of course you know there will be
there would be providers which are which
would be our number one number two but
then every pointer has got something
really good which can be used in your
product and unless until you are aware
and you are knowledgeable on that you
would not be able to propose that as
part of an organization so my suggestion
would be as you grow further it is it
would really help to be you know to be
certified and knowledgeable on other
platforms as well well that makes good
sense we talk about sometimes being a
t-shaped professional right where you
have a horizontal understanding of a
variety of skill sets deeply enough to
be able to be to be able to have the
vocabulary and and discuss them
reasonably and then deep knowledge and
one or two specialties so that makes
sense maybe you're a super specialist on
AWS or glacier but you have some working
understanding of some of the other
platforms as well to broaden your your
your skill set and make yourself just
that much more valuable in the work in
the marketplace all right well we're at
9:28 my time 28 minutes after the hour
so even though we started a little bit
late I don't see any other questions in
the system so I think that we're still
able to finish up at our allotted
originally scheduled time I do want
everybody who's still with us to take a
look in the chat module you'll see that
I shared a few links with you there
one of them is a link to the course page
on simply learned for the AWS courses
that are available I've also linked you
to the career edge page dealing with AWS
and cloud they're there you're going to
find not only a courses that are
relevant but also free resources like
articles and ebooks and white papers and
that sort of thing that you can access
if it's if it's valuable
just for fun I also shared a link to
Amazon's FAQ page on glacier and from
there you can click around and also get
into the FAQ is relevant to s3 so if
you've got additional questions you
might find that some of them are
addressed there and then the last thing
is just a link to the career edge page
of the top-level career edge page on our
simply learned site where you can click
around and find information on upcoming
webinars resources white papers and and
so forth across all of the specialties
that we we address so from that page you
can filter by cloud or by Microsoft or
by digital marketing or whatever other
areas of interest you might have and
find additional resources so with that
said my ugh thank you so much do you
have anything on any last thing to add
there do you have anything you want me
to share I think I think it has been
wonderful guys just just just well you
know some of some of the few words from
my side would be this is the right time
this is the right time to get into to
get into cloud computing and if you are
if you are planning to if you are
planning to do to the next big thing in
your career it is time to go ahead and
learn cloud computing and learn it in a
Cell on it in a way that you will be
able to do it practical work is very
very important so it it is it is going
to be some amount of theory and a lot of
practicals as you do that you are going
to learn it go learn that get certified
and do the next jump in your period on
the best
you